hey guys it's max we just got in
samsung's new galaxy buds
live i'm excited to check them out and
compare them to my airpods pro
that i've been using ever since they
came out these are fantastic
but now we have a competitor the first
galaxy buzz that have
active noise cancellation let's go ahead
and
take these out it's interesting i
thought this little case would be larger
i like how small they kept it
look at that size it's a little thicker
but i love it more compact too
all right moment of truth
now those look nice way nicer than the
case
that actually matches my apple watch and
they don't call these gold right
they call them bronze i don't know why
that looks like gold
interesting they have more weight than i
expected
so let's pull one of these out i'll pull
out one of my air pods here
it's the airpod pro the shorter stem
definitely a unique shape looks like a
little bean
and i'm glad that samsung decided to do
something different something more
interesting than trying to
you know copy apple or do what they've
been doing
before we do a sound comparison and the
noise cancellation comparison
let's connect them there you go popped
up automatically
bam that is done now before we listen to
these bad boys and compare them i want
to let you know that i'm going to take
about a week and i'm going to dish my
airpods pros
try out the galaxy buzz live see how
they work day to day
and how they compare and then do my
review so make sure you guys are
subscribed and have those notifications
enabled
i also want to mention the battery life
both these cases do support wireless
charging and have batteries
built into them the samsung's all
together
with the battery inside the case will
get you about 21 hours compared to over
24 with the airpod pros
but when you're using just the actual
earbuds themselves
samsung does win out you can get up to
eight hours if you don't use active
noise cancellation or the bixby
listening feature whereas the airpods
will give you up to five hours the
galaxy buttons are slightly
better and let's try these on i don't
even know
exactly how to put these things in oh
that that is weird i'm hearing my music
ready
how does that look with you looks pretty
flat i know i need to get a haircut but
it's interesting definitely a different
feeling okay okay
well i'm used to my airpod pros i'm used
to how they feel
this definitely fills in the outside of
my ear so you can feel it that it's
there but it doesn't
feel uncomfortable so it's pretty much
flush with my ear so if you're somebody
that rides bikes if you want to wear
headphones
listen music while you're doing that uh
you'll be able to slip stuff over your
head and
put a helmet on or whatever and it's not
gonna fall out or get pushed out
so let's jump into our sound test and
obviously i don't have the airpod pro
sound but i'm going to
take a quick listen just to refresh my
mind
and it's still weird the shape here
but it goes in actually not not too bad
okay
all right moment of truth
the bass
which one is louder as far as you list
hearing them
i can hear the buzz way way louder so
the butts he can hear way louder
um i want to see if i can tweak these
settings the bass is
ah sounds great so i just went through
all the different modes and
surprisingly normal actually sounds the
best it's the loudest
and the bass just sounds nice it's a
nice balanced sound
it sounds fantastic i'm gonna put my
airpod pros back in
and take a listen uh i don't know this
might have just ruined the airpod pros
for me at least sound quality wise
doesn't sound terrible let's go back to
these
gosh
yeah they sound nice they sound really
nice
sound quality wise good job samsung you
did it
these things sound fantastic now the
next question
how good is the active noise
cancellation i'll start out with the
buds live and i have to mention these
are not
a sealed design and it's weird because
apple went from having a non-sealed with
air pods to a sealed for noise
cancellation
samsung went the opposite but let's pop
them in and samsung mentioned they get
rid of 97
of low sounds and we have a central ac
there it's blowing right now it's an
annoying low sound
i definitely notice a difference my
voice sounds a lot higher now
and that vent that's right up there i
still hear the air that's coming out of
it but not the low parts of it
and it almost sounds a little bit more
annoying instead of like this low
droning sound i hear like this
like this higher end sound so it sounds
like it's not getting rid of everything
just those low noises
wow so that this is weird
i'm hearing more of the low sound it
didn't get rid of as much of the low
droning sound but it got rid of all of
that high frequency noise
of the air going through the vents i
don't hear that at all
that's really funny i definitely prefer
the airpod pros for noise cancellation
let's try out the buds plus i'm just
curious how that compares without
active just using a sealed design
that's weird again i hear a lot less
noise with these ones even though they
don't have active noise cancellation
they're not even turned on they're dead
right now
but i'm getting most of that sound from
that vent is blocked out my voice sounds
a lot lower than normal
not as good as the airpod pros but
actually
better than these galaxy buds
live yeah that's not very good
honestly personally i would just keep
the active noise cancellation turned off
because it's more annoying with it on at
least in our environment here
now let's compare the microphones this
was pretty much the weakest point of the
previous galaxy buds
samsung says it made a lot of
improvements the new galaxy buds live
have three microphones compared to two
with the airpods pro let's go ahead and
do a voice recorder and you guys let me
know which one
sounds better this is the microphone
quality with the galaxy buds life
and this is the microphone quality with
apple's earpods pro so what is
my final verdict well i have to just say
that
samsung i am impressed for 170 bucks
the battery life that you have them
especially with that noise cancellation
off eight hours that is excellent
the sound quality is excellent i
personally love how they look especially
these gold ones
and that they're flush in the in your
ears it just sounds like a
great value i think people are going to
really enjoy using these
now the sound cancellation on here i
feel like they just added that
just to have it on the box because
everybody's doing active noise
cancellation
it sounds worse than the previous galaxy
buzz that doesn't have it because it's
not a steel design
don't buy for active noise cancellation
unless you have some kind of low noise
with no medium or high frequency sound
at all
maybe it will work for that so if you're
using an android device man these offer
a great
value now the earpods these don't sound
as good
they're more expensive but the noise
cancellation works fantastic so if you
need noise cancellation
even on an android phone these sound
great now i still have some questions
one how is the comfort for long term use
i'll be covering that in my full
review and how well do these work on an
iphone that's exactly what i'm going to
be doing
for the next week and doing a dedicated
video for iphone users that are
interested in these
make sure you guys are subscribed you
guys have notifications enabled
once again we have links down in the
video description and if you want one of
these
ultra premium comfortable modern apple
product shirts
or one of our other designs or a mask
check out the merch shelf
down below this has been max and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]